PROFESSOR: I want to use this
applet, Amplitude and Phase:
First Order, to show you some
of the functionalities that
are common to the MIT mathlets.
First of all, if your browser
window looks like this,
so that the label at
the top is too large,
or like this, so that it's
missing some of the window,
it's because you have the zoom
on your browser set wrong.
And you can adjust it
with command or control
plus or minus keys, so
that it looks correct.
So let's see what we
have in this applet.
At the top, you can see
the differential equation
that this applet deals with.
This differential
equation models
many different
physical phenomena,
and the story I want to tell
you involves the ocean, measured
by this blue level
here, connected to a bay
by this channel.
And here's a measure of
the water level in the bay.
As time goes on,
the level of water
in the ocean changes
because of tides,
and the water level
in the bay follows
suit mediated by a slanting
level in the channel.
I'm dragging this time slider
under the graphing window,
and you can set it
wherever you want.
In fact, if you want to
set it at exactly 12,
because there's a hash mark
here, I can click on this 12,
and the time slider
moves to that point.
Or you can return time to
time zero by this arrow key,
and then animate by pushing
this double right arrow key
and watch the tide
move up and down.
There's very carefully
designed color
coding in all of these applets.
In this case, blue
represents the ocean,
and you can see that
it also represents
the curve traced out by
the height of the ocean
as time increases.
And yellow represents the
water level in the bay.
When I drag the cursor
over this graphing window,
you can see a crosshair
forming, and below the window,
you can see readout of time
and the x variable, vertical
direction.
You can use this to
make measurements.
For example, I can see
that the tide in the bay
seems to have maximal
height of 0.38.
In many of these applets,
you can make measurements
by using a rollover over
the graphing window.
Let's see what else we
have in this applet.
Down here, there's
a slider marked k.
This is the coupling constant.
It reflects the width of
the channel in the story
that I'm telling you.
When k is small, the
channel is very narrow
and the ocean level
has very little effect
on the water level in the bay.
In fact, when k is equal to
zero, it has no effect at all.
On the other hand,
when k becomes larger,
the water level in the bay
tracks the ocean water level
very closely.
Let's set k to one, here.
And think about another
thing you can vary.
In reality, you can't change
the period of the tides.
Even King Canute
couldn't do that.
But here in this tool, we can.
And I can vary the circular
frequency of this tidal input
signal by changing the omega
slider over here on the right.
I can make it small, and so the
period is very long, or larger
and make the tides
happen faster.
So we can animate this again.
You can see things
happen faster.
The curve is tighter, and
the effect is different.
In fact, if we watch what
happens when I move omega
from one down to
a smaller number,
you can see the maximum
height of the tide changes.
The amplitude of
the tide changes.
It depends upon omega.
In fact, one of the nice
things about these systems
is that if you have a sinusoidal
input-- as we do here,
this blue curve--
then the output signal
is also going to be sinusoidal
and of the same frequency.
So there's only
two things we need
to know about the output
here, this yellow signal.
Namely, the amplitude
and the phase
lag behind the input
signal, the blue curve.
And those two quantities can
be measured, can be graphed,
against the input frequency,
and we can see those graphs
by clicking on this check box
called Bode Plots down here.
So this opens two new windows.
The upper one
records the amplitude
as a function of the
angular input frequency,
and the lower one
records the number
of degrees behind the input
frequency that the bay falls.
So as omega changes, you can
see all these various things
changing simultaneously.
This is a characteristic
feature of these applets.
The same information is recorded
in several different places
and always connected
visually by placement.
So you can see the
amplitude is 0.71 here.
This yellow horizontal
line connects it
with the maxima of
the output curve.
And also by color.
What else do we see here?
There's a red line segment
here on this curve, which
I can make a little bit bigger
if I decrease the k a bit
and decrease the
frequency a little bit.
What is this red curve
here, this red line here?
Well, it connects to
this vertical strut
which goes up to the
maximum of the output curve.
And it begins at the
maximum of the input curve.
In other words, it's
the amount of time
that the output falls
behind the input.
It's the time lag,
and that time lag
is recorded
numerically down here.
It's 1.96 in this example.
There's one more
check box to explore
called Nyquist Plot here.
Let's click it and
see what happens.
This opens a window
at the bottom here
which records a complex number.
That complex number contains
a magnitude and an angle.
And the magnitude is the
amplitude of the system
response, and the angle
represents the phase lag
of the system response.
You can see these things
changing together when
I move the omega slider here.
Watch both the windows above
the slider and the window
below the slider, and you can
see that they change together.
This bottom representation
is a complex number.
It's very useful in
understanding the relationship
between phase lag and
amplitude, and it also
represents the way we
solve these differential
equations in the Differential
Equations course at MIT.
This is just a
beginning and indication
of some of the functionalities
of these MIT mathlets.
If you want to see
a list of them that
are associated any
one of the applets,
there's always a Help key in the
upper right hand corner which
will open a page
that simply describes
the functionalities present
in that particular applet.
So have fun with these.
You can play around with them.
You can't break anything
by clicking buttons
and experimenting with rollovers
and moving the sliders.